thirty seconds god bless the Richie
famous we are the modern day magicians
siphoning bank accounts out of theater
I'm not sure if Chicagoans are as awful
as watchdogs would have me believe
according to this exciting open-world
action game the residents of the Windy
City are chronic [ __ ] criminals
cannibals slavers and social medians
they may think their secrets are safe
but Aiden Pearce can hack into the
city's surveillance network which
controls and seize nearly everything
with a computer chip Aidan knows who you
are and what you've been up to
watchdogs sometimes tries to grapple
with hard issues but rarely digs very
deeply this is a game that allows you to
hacking the highway billboards to have
them display tired internet memes when
the story tries to say something
meaningful about what makes one life
more valuable than another the tone is
disrupted when you hack into someone's
home security and discover him preparing
a snack of human fingers a tease quest
to avenge the persons that caused the
car crash that killed his niece picks up
steam about halfway through but the
game's themes never coalesce watchdogs
can never quite figure out whether it's
serious or silly shot its tone may not
be consistent but watchdogs is still an
excellent open-world playground that
shines because it's many individual
pieces are so wonderfully executed take
a typical combat encounter Aiden hunkers
close to the ground and you survey the
area by hacking into security cameras
and marking your enemies some enemies
carry grenades that you can detonate
remotely sometimes you can disable a
guards ability to call in reinforcements
try throwing a distraction ler towards a
circuit board and detonate the board
when a nearby guard approached ha's try
disrupting an enemy's communication
systems and assassinate him from behind
while he struggles with the screeching
in his ear you can shoot your way
through too and have lots of fun with
the loud rock solid arsenal but that's
the easy way there's greater
satisfaction in being clever
Chicago is simply loaded with really fun
stuff to do
you can lose yourself solving smart
chess based puzzles or shooting up
aliens in one of watchdog's
augmented reality games even the
smallest activities are fully engaging
though the for optional minigame is
called digital trips deserve special
mention in the best of these you gain
control of a humongous spider bot
battering police cars and leaping up the
sides of buildings the action is frantic
in the best possible way moving from one
activity to the next involves zooming
through the streets and watchdogs bouncy
vehicles as you speed along you can
trigger steam pipes beneath the streets
to erupt and take down your foes or
cause traffic jams by hacking into
streetlights the best moments behind the
wheel are those who share online
watchdogs single-player missions and
multiplayer activities are merged into a
single experience and the game
frequently and annoyingly nags you with
opportunities to engage with others the
best of the multiplayer modes is
decryption in which two teams of four
are confined to a portion of the city
and seek to nab and hold on to sensitive
data the result is pure captivating
anarchy
[Music]
data is passed around whether you're in
vehicles are on foot in any given minute
you might ram into a motorcyclist and
watch his body fly above your windshield
a teammate might leap into your
vehicle's passenger seat and fire a
rifle at the ice cream truck giving you
chase whether you're dealing death by
shotgun or by cement truck it's
difficult not to be swept up in the
pandemonium online invasions are less
explosive than other modes and
potentially more boring depending on how
the invasion goes as the invader you
come close to your target press a button
to begin downloading data and wait as
the victim you rush around or hack into
nearby cameras scanning the crowd for
your invader neither running around
looking for your hacker nor avoiding her
watchful eye is engaging on its own but
catching the data thief initiates a
chase sequence that leads to watchdogs
special brand of pandemonium
you can simply ignore all these
possibilities and remain a lone
vigilante of course infiltrating gang
hideouts is much like performing many of
the story missions you search for a way
into the danger zone and decide how best
to proceed the wonder of watchdogs is
that any method is reasonable and every
method is enjoyable watch dogs is an
all-action
you can hack into CTOs centers for
instance each of which presents an
environmental puzzle to solve so that
you might reveal more hotspots on your
map many of these puzzles are rather
clever as is the hacking minigame that
gives you access to high-security server
rooms where audio logs and other Secrets
await there is simply a ton of stuff to
do and watchdogs from solving a murder
and visiting historical locales to
hacking bank accounts and withdrawing
the money from an ATM the game may try
to take itself seriously but when you're
racing through the canals in a speedboat
with a police chopper on your tail it's
hard to think beyond the thrills in prod
Damien it's over I'm his
you
[Music]